[Music]
did you watch uh the channel five
complex con no yeah not yet
yeah
fashion sucks
that was my takeaway from this
it's just 25 minutes of like oh my
[ __ ] god oh by the way the twins that
yeah right here
these guys they were in our music video
those are the guys in sofia yeah
again yeah i got the toys right there
like
what does it mean to drip this right
here you see it what is dripped uniform
right but would you wear these to work
all right the way i the whole style the
whole this the vibe of it all would you
show up to work like this you work at
7-eleven i don't i'm a model actor
creative with my twitter right here
what's up doc what's up
cut them off mid-sentence wow
wow
you know what's impressive about those
dudes is they they do work a lot
like in
just like just oh yeah yeah i believe
that they have like a super distinct
look and they're twins i mean that has
to get them booked for a lot of [ __ ]
nemo showed up on like some big set and
he was like the [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's just like i don't know like
some of the [ __ ] that people are wearing
in this oh i'm sure it's just ridiculous
everyone's just out like hypebeasting
each other yeah
talking about the culture and it's just
just a mismatch
what's the word i'm looking for mismatch
yeah
mishmash yeah this guy you know him ass
pizza
my brother started that we're about to
get sent to virginia we're about to get
sent to the navy you feel me and when i
was out there we started about the
company now we're a million dollar
company i'm doing that [ __ ] i don't give
a [ __ ] about the cloud everything we're
doing i'm living in and that's it hey yo
have you seen this hair design
everywhere have you seen it on the
internet though
ask everybody where they got that [ __ ]
from tell me where it started
they're gonna look at me
i like the hair the hair looks sick oh
thank you bro
oh thank you bro where did they get this
[ __ ] a spider
third grade
charlotte charlotte's website asking
where they got it ask them where they
got this charlotte's web oh i've known
about that design since i was a baby
yeah
charlotte's web yeah itsy bitsy yeah
ever since then yeah
ask them where they got it
i think that's the funniest part is like
when you see young people start oh by
the way i have to double back what a
modern sentence you just dished out
there yeah do you know asp you know this
guy asked pizza yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's the guy who started the
printer company that got bought by
gwyneth paltrow yeah she teamed up with
garyvee and they made an nft firm and
they bought his printing
nfts it's uh actually uh uh scratch and
sniff nfts that smell like gwyneth's
[ __ ] yeah but you can scratch them
through the screen coop yeah a scoop
pizza yeah yeah yeah
really innovative stuff
yeah i don't know i just uh what were we
gonna say
i was gonna say that i think it's funny
when
you know young um creatives get
interviewed
and
you know it makes sense like you're
young you gotta believe in your ideas
and they say some [ __ ] and then everyone
older than 25 is like
that's uh like a literally a 500 year
old thought yeah but you just had it
yeah like you just had that thought for
the first time yeah but you have no clue
that thousands of years of civilization
have existed before you and they all
thought that yeah but that's cool man
yeah
that's sick no no you did invent the
spider yeah
no for sure man definitely first guy to
put a spider web on his head
yeah yeah never mind like the
multi-million dollar franchise where a
guy does that on a whole suit yeah but i
just think it's funny like the whole
um i don't know like everyone everyone
there's this similar
undertone of everyone's interviews where
everyone was like no that guy's stealing
off me i'm the originator of this and
like we're really out here doing it yeah
it's like you guys are all doing it
you're doing the same thing you have a
shopify business mm-hmm
that's it you know which is impressive
that's not an easy thing but like it's
just everyone's competing with each
other like for how
real they are yeah
and when that's all in one place it's
like oh god yeah i also love that he
says uh [ __ ] you on like
[ __ ] the population like
ftp like that brand yeah exactly like
that brand has been huge forever yeah
yeah
he's just kind of making a slight change
yeah
yeah
yeah
um did i tell you about the von dutch
documentary no
so first of all [ __ ] watch that it's
insanely good it is insanely good is
that on youtube tv it's on hulu
you can get that via youtube tv
um
it is a wild story and what's cool is
that the original von dutch was an
artist he was a pinstriper
and he has this really cool manifesto
that he wrote
um it's like about
you should never commodify art or
something no it's about how
yeah basically it's about how everything
is everything has been done and
nothing's original
and so he's like you can take everything
that i've done and it's you know
creative comments basically you can take
it and use it for whatever commercially
whatever because
as artists we have to know that
everything is an iteration on something
that's already been done and
everything's been done already wow so
it's just art is just copying people
over and over again and putting your
little spin on it what and what not
which was really cool so that's why they
were able to use the logo and his
pinstriping and everything and sell it
on clothes
but i just it just brings me back to
that guy inventing the spider yeah yeah
exactly come on now thomas i've seen tom
holland rocking that [ __ ] recently yeah
yeah it was like on a suit yeah yeah
yeah he took that super fire man yeah
you invented that [ __ ] that's sick he
should give you credit stan lee took
that [ __ ] from you yeah he's [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] up he's dead now
um so i don't know you might have died
before you were born but that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's [ __ ] dude
that's the literal [ __ ] that he took
that from you man you should watch that
documentary though no i will it's really
really really crazy
isn't that so wild how uh
like urban outfitters that was their
money maker for so long just like
creative commons with nasa yeah and then
and then uh what's who's our buddy craig
tyler create tyler no they stole that
from create tyler actually you're right
yeah crete tyler invented that
definitely yelling to that yeah i'm the
boy
you know what another crazy netflix show
i watched recently was the the puppet
master do you see that one
limited series like three episodes so
it's super short it's just about this
guy that's a
con man okay and uh he convinced his
college roommates that he was an mi5
agent and they went on the run for 10
years
and he stole money from their families
and would just siphon money from them
the story is told in two parts and so
they keep fast forwarding and rewinding
through time
and
so current day they start with an
interview
uh with basically this family and
they're like the way this the show
starts is if you want to say something
to your mom right now if she was
watching what would you say and the kids
are like mom we don't blame you for any
of this like we really just want you
back in our lives
and then the story starts unraveling and
you learn that that guy currently
is with their mom and has been
basically scamming her and their family
for like 10 years and they haven't seen
her in 10 years and then it rewinds and
it shows that he's been doing this his
entire life
how
it's [ __ ] crazy i gotta see this mi5
yeah
oh i like convinced oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i saw this on my the
recommended yeah i'm definitely gonna
watch this
i'm trying to think i've been watching
the wire oh yeah is that i mean i
watched the first season i remember it's
like being floored how good it was yeah
for especially for the time yeah
despite all the ass cinematography
not enough
not enough dicks though
yeah it seems to be modern tv just
penises yeah well i come to expect that
now though